The Witcher 3 s blood and wine expansion
pack drops very soon but before garold
can journey to the land of twistle we're
all going to need to download a patch
patch 1.20 brings plenty of tweaks and
bug fixes that should make the final
chapter of gerelds journey the best it
can be here's what to expect first off
you'll have a new option to turn on
enemy upscaling that means that weaker
enemies will be raised to a level
comparable to yours even if you visit
older areas the other big fix is a real
godsend there's a new book called a
miraculous guide to gwent and it
provides a checklist of all the Gwent
cards you have all the cards you don't
have and some info on where to find them
there are a handful of other graphical
and performance tweaks in there too but
those two big changes should make you
all very happy [ __ ] and wine comes to
ps4 xbox one and pc on May 31st and it's
the final chapter of The Witcher 3 saga
will have a review and plenty of other
coverage up on gamespot and for all you
need to know on CD projekt red's
upcoming games you're already in the
right place
you